kathy has experienced violence twice her
father was shot dead by the bee specials
a part-time reserve police force
my wedding day i had enough father to
walk me up the aisle i hadn't had a
father my my children had been born
twenty years later she herself survived
an ira bombing it claimed the lives of
three policemen and a nun she lives with
that trauma but there's other days when
you're dying and possibly you've heard
something on the news
you've been a memory has been triggered
and is brought back there's never a
doubles by that i don't think of sister
catherine and the three policemen who
were murdered
these portraits bear silent testimony to
the cost of the troubles each of the
subjects lost a loved one i would invite
brandon lewis and
boris johnson to look into the eyes of
each of the 18 people and then
to tell me how they don't count the
artist understands the challenge of
addressing the past but says it doesn't
compare with what these people endured
it's an easier task
to deal with the past
than it is to pick up
the limbs and body parts of your loved
one
after they've been blown to bits on the
street
it's an easier task to deal with the
past
than it is to bury
your only child
who was killed
because of the street that they grew up
on
under pressure to halt historical
prosecutions the government had proposed
a de facto amnesty for both british army
veterans and terrorists but those
involved in killings will now have to
earn immunity by cooperating with the
truth recovery process effectively
giving victims a choice between truth
and justice the the process of justice
has never knocked on their door and i
would be concerned about that
kathy wants to move on but victims say
they're entitled to truth and justice
not one or the other
david blevins sky news in armagh